good luck to my opponents Marcus Herman
style c3 do you take c3 Knight takes c3
mayhem amaura knight c6 let's play
Knight f3
hmm it's Queen c7 Bishop c4 e6 you have
to remember this
short Castle Knight f6 it's funny this
is the line that I play as black so it's
like I'm playing against myself I think
the move here is Knight d5 hitting in
Queen there's some really interesting
lines actually usually black has to go
for like Queen beats believe No so I'm
attacking the knight
Knight takes e5 yeah let's take that
takes e5 Queen takes e5 and I believe
rook e1 this is some like random mark
Esserman preparation so the queen is
tied down to c7 whoa Queen c5 hmm I mean
I could play Bishop f4 maybe Bishop f4
Queen takes c4 and then Knight c7 that
looks really fun so I'm down I'm down to
pawns but I have a massive amount of
pieces in play and threatening mainly
threatening night c7 there's ideas of
rooks e1
yeah life is pretty good where's my tea
maybe my tea
I can't find my tea I honestly can't
find my tea that's troublesome d6 okay
so stopping 97 hmm I could take on
complete Bishop takes d6 play rooks you
won yeah let's play works you won black
3 minutes 12 seconds
mm-hmm very close one time I again
forgot to check of those increments so
what's my threat baby I'm threatening
Knight see 797 Queen takes e7 Bishop b5
winning Queen hmm so I could still play
Knight c7 I could play Bishop III maybe
taking on d6 finite c7 simplify a bit
King d7 hmm King d7 so I can take on ate
it all so baby should be five
there should be five King d5 the D funds
pinned also the Queen's hanging forgot
about the Queen's for loans complete
Bishop b5 let's just take upon weight
the bishop black starts for Bishop is
still on I fake no it's on e7 okay I
play Bishop there should be five King D
866 it's almost meaning King d8 Bishop
takes d6 Bishop takes d6 Queen takes d6
check Bishop d7 rook c7 okay going in
for the kill three move rook d7 room
takes d7 check King c8z seven checkmate
okay some nice opening preparation oh
yeah honestly I think this the first
time I ever like discovered this opening
oh my T's right in front of me I was in
frame two I was like feeling all around
and that it's like right next to the mic
you